That's what was wrong.
I was like, why does it sound weird?
I had something off because I was recording earlier.
This song is terrible.
Get me out of here.
Get me out of here, please.
Guys, things are a little scuffed on my end, I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, why did the music disappear?
Is it because I said the music was horrible?
Um...
Uh...
Where did the music go?
To this...
Stream, it's really... Look at my cursor.
I don't know if we're gonna make it.
I'm gonna be honest.
I
can barely see anything.
My...
My window is so...
Tiny.
Kitty, good kitty!
Congratulations!
It's...
So itty-bitty.
I tried a lot.
I did try.
But we're gonna just see what happens.
Baby!
As long as you guys can see it, I guess it's fine.
Um...
See, it's working.
It's working.
Beep boop boop.
Beep beep boop boop boop.
Use your tiny monitor!
Wait, I probably could.
Um...
But yeah, look at the load runner.
Uh...
Someone was just like, Oh, I wonder if Mint ever played this game?
And I was like...
Yeah!
How do I take the gold?
It's me!
I take the gold!
Run.
How do I take the gold?
Go.
Oh!
What just happened?
Oh my god.
I just had like a...
A vision.
Oh my god, I'm here!
Look at me go!
And then you climb up and we gotta take the gold.
Wait, let me move my cursor.
Do we even need this?
Oh!
Wait!
Oh my god.
I guess we're taking the gold, everybody.
Wait, just fall down.
What?
When he falls, it's so funny.
And then there will be bad guys sometimes that like...
Are scary...
I'm not doing the most optimal...
Uh...
Route for this, probably.
Hi!
Oh, there's the door!
I was like, how do I get out of here?
Wah!
Lord and Lord!
Yeah!
We did it!
Oh my gosh.
How am I supposed to get down there?
Oh.
Wait, how do I do any of this?
Wait, okay.
I think I can climb across this.
Wait.
I can't...
No, go down.
Go down.
Okay, I can't go down.
It's impossible.
He can only climb up.
He's only an up man.
But how do I go down?
It's impossible.
Wait, I can jump?
What the hell was that?
That was so...
I love platforming.
Use your gun.
I have a gun.
How do I shoot?
Dig...
Diggy hole.
How?
What's the...
What's the control for dig?
All I know is...
All I know is left and right.
Is there a pause?
No.
Oh!
Sticky keys.
No sticky keys, please!
Oh.
At least the time's not going up, right?
That's my cursor.
Where did the music go?
Why can't I go down the stairs?
Or the ladder?
Okay, hold on.
Oh, shoot.
I did it again.
Okay.
Uh...
Wow, that is small.
I'm telling you!
I'm not pressing the right down.
Guys, this is so scuffed.
How did...
How does anyone from the 90s exist?
How did you guys do it?
How did you survive?
How are you alive?
Manuals.
Okay, I'm gonna Google it.
That's so true.
What's a manual?
Nope.
Load runner.
Legend returns manual.
Let's see what the system requirements are.
Macintosh.
Do you guys have that?
You could play.
Found one of my favorite artists and music for Death Stranding 2.
Including one of the soundtracks called, and now the bonus tracks.
Featuring Hideo Kojima where Kojima says...
Wait, sorry.
I can't read the...
It's too fast.
I can't get out of the game.
But thank you!
Oh.
Do I look like I got past the fifth level of this?
You failed it.
Oh.
The other requirements are Windows.
Intel 486...
5?
No.
486SX25MHZ or better CPU.
Hard drive with 12 megabytes free.
One 3.5 inch high density drive.
Or...
MS-DOS.
What does Macintosh need?
Macintosh computer.
Hard drive with 12 megabytes free.
Oh, you do need a card.
You need a card.
640x400256 color.
System 6.0.7 or better.
Yeah.
Sound card support.
Any 100% supported Windows sound card.
Interface.
Keyboard, mouse, and joystick.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I don't have a joystick.
How ambitious I know.
256.
Okay, wait.
Hold on.
I'm trying to find the...
Okay, so...
This...
These are our li...
Oh, sorry.
You can't see.
Sorry.
This is...
These are our lives.
This is my score, which is definitely zero.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm on the ladder.
Okay.
And then...
This...
I don't know what that is.
Oh!
Level being played.
Okay.
And then I have tools eventually.
I will have them in here.
Oh!
Okay, it's a numpad!
It's numpad!
Climb down.
Wait.
Okay, hold on.
Oh my god!
It's numpad.
Run right.
Oh my gosh.
Everything is the numpad.
Blast a hole.
Blast...
Blast a hole right.
I don't think I have it.
Drops a bomb.
I don't have it.
Pick up a tool.
Are there any tools?
This game is offering nothing to me.
Wait.
I can climb down here.
Watch this.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I'm a little monkey.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Can you imagine if I didn't have a keyboard with a numpad on it?
I would be so screwed.
It's amazing how you can control the game with your humongous brain powers.
Or maybe someone else is playing.
What are you talking about?
Someone else is playing.
Wait.
Why are there two cursors?
That's mysterious.
Happy birthday, Michael!
Yeah.
You might be able to play this.
Okay.
Hold on.
Blast a hole right.
Climb down.
Climb up.
Use tool.
Maybe I need to use my tool.
I have none.
I have no tool.
Do you guys see a tool?
I'm supposed to be blasting right now.
I don't.
Use tool.
Oh shoot.
Guys.
Wait.
You can't see anything.
Oh.
It fixed itself.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
It fixed itself.
We're fine.
We got a good promotion today.
Think back.
Congrats.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Oh.
I'm trapped now.
Oh gosh.
I got the...
I got it wrong.
Wait.
You can die.
Everybody.
Uh oh.
Okay.
Yes.
Let me go up here.
I'm guessing we can't...
Blast a hole.
I'm guessing we can't blast a hole...
On the...
The...
What's it called?
Tile area.
Pew.
Monkey, monkey, monkey.
Monkey, monkey, monkey, monkey, monkey.
Okay.
The stone.
Yes.
I'm a little...
Guys.
I realized I had so much coffee today.
I apologize.
Yeah.
Level two.
All it took was figuring out...
That I needed to use numpad.
Wow.
That's all.
I accidentally had so much coffee.
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Because your hands are on the screen.
You must be using some sort of telekinetic powers.
I have one hand on the screen.
Now two.
Oh my god.
It's the enemy.
He's finally here.
Oh, this is sick.
Oh my god.
He's fast.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, buddy.
We can talk about this.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
He's coming!
Nah, he's going.
Wow!
He doesn't even know where I am.
He's fine.
Take that.
Okay.
He's really stupid, actually.
Okay, the AI is really dumb.
The AI is so dumb.
Oh my god, oh my god!
No, no, this is messed up.
He's spawn camping!
Right now!
Oh my god, I'm in trouble.
Sayonara, suckers.
He's dumb.
I like how it took a long, long time to load.
Uh... Oh... Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Watch this.
Why is it... Why is it... Why is it... You guys, it's kind of... Wait, what just happened?
It's... It's, um... Taking a little bit of... It's...
I'm getting robbed!
Why is it lagging so bad all of a sudden?
How do they know how to climb?
But not me!
I don't know how to climb!
You can walk on their heads, I can?
Oh, he just dropped some gold.
Idiot.
Okay.
Oh, shoot, I just noticed... Do I have to collect the skulls, too?
I just noticed the one down there.
You can walk on the red guy.
Wish that was me.
It could be you!
Oh my gosh, next con.
New convention idea.
The meet and walk.
I...
Meet you, walk on you.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Okay, actually, this is doable.
Maybe.
They're kind of scaring me.
They're a little close, but...
They're a little...
Why is the music stop?
It's stressing me out.
Guys, I feel like I could play this for a really long time.
You know?
Except it's really laggy right now, because we have many men.
Many, many men!
Three men is too many on the screen.
Oh, well, I guess technically four, because there's me, too.
You're down?
Okay.
Whoa!
Run, run, run!
I'm the load runner!
Whisp...
Whisp what?
Okay, where's the door?
Down here.
Oh, up here.
Perfect.
Perfect, perfect, perfect.
I did this actually exactly how you're supposed to, it seems.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Oh, they're stuck.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Wait, what are you guys doing?
Oh, no.
Be-doop.
Perfect sequence.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, there I am up there.
Is he going to monkey?
Oh, dang.
Okay.
Uh, let's see.
Hat dag.
There's just two pieces.
I don't think it's worth it.
I think we should go home.
Hi, Mickey.
How are you today?
I'm great.
Does the meet and walk come with or without shoes?
Probably like a bowling alley kind of situation where you rent them.
Meet and walk would be best if what?
If your screen and camera are mounted on the scaled-down Metal Gear Rex.
Oh, yeah.
Hi, Mito.
Hi.
Okay.
This guy, he's...
He's...
He doesn't know what he's doing.
Shut up.
There's hidden...
Hidden money.
I'm gonna shoot him.
I become so much faster when I'm a monkey.
No!
Oh.
Hey, buddy.
Let's talk about this.
Okay.
I'm glad he doesn't grab my toes.
Easy does it.
Da-da-da-da-da!
And where's the door?
Right there.
Easy peasy.
I can't get got by one guy.
As much as it happens to me on stream.
Let's go load right now!
The game does not like this level.
The game is really struggling right now.
Wait.
I don't think I did the correct sequence, everybody.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
I think I did too many.
Oh, he's climbing on the...
Wait.
I might be a genius.
Oh, I might be a genius.
Holy moly.
Oh my gosh, please.
You guys, I have to collect the jewels or we won't be able to...
Wait.
Ow.
Maybe I'm not a genius.
Oh wow.
How do I drop down?
Oh my god, scary.
Oh wow.
How do I...
Oh, I think I have to drop.
Okay.
Maybe I drop...
And drop.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
It's chugging along.
It's really chugging.
You got this game!
You can do it!
Um, excuse me!
Um...
I know!
I gotta do it.
I gotta drop.
Ah!
I gotta do it!
He respawned!
They can do that!
That's really evil.
Wait, so I can't just kill him?
Do they have magical powers?
Okay.
Alright, we're almost there.
Go.
I have a feeling it's gonna...
Spawn...
In the...
Top left.
That little area.
You see it?
Okay.
Okay, I see it.
I knew it.
Oh my god, it's a race against the clock!
Go, my man!
Go!
The lag is really just adding to the intensity of this now, isn't it?
Okay.
Wow!
Don't sp...
Did he just take that money?
Wait, they can take the money?
Don't do that.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Go, die, die, die, die, die, die.
I took your money.
Grew up playing, load.
Okay.
He died.
Nice.
You grew up playing this game?
Is that what you said?
Sorry.
This is intense.
I have to have my full focus on...
Uh-oh.
Oh no, oh no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh no, no, no, no, no.
Not for me.
For you, dad.
Played this one so much as a kid.
I remember.
I...
I remember my papa playing this so much.
I don't think I ever played it.
Now that I...
Now that I am actually playing it.
I am dead though, I know.
Tactical retreat.
Kind of.
Don't take that money.
Don't you dare.
Okay, this is actually good.
Because they're kind of just sticking to the ladders.
They're actually a little dumb.
Wait, this is good.
He took my money.
Okay.
I don't like how it like suddenly becomes...
A little spooky.
You know?
Um, excuse me, sir.
Excuse me.
Thank you.
Oh no.
Oh no, no.
Oh no, no, no, no.
Uh oh.
Oh no, no, no, no, no.
Oh no, no, no.
Oh no, no.
Okay, run, run, run.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Ah, ah, ah, ah.
That was kind of scary.
I wasn't paying attention.
I was looking at you guys.
Smooth AF?
Mm-hmm.
This game becomes way too scary when it involves men.
The, the, the, I don't like these guys.
Can I have a please a little bit of peace while I grave rob?
Please.
I just want a little bit of peace while I grave rob.
I'm making, I'm snaking my way up here.
Wait, can he get to me?
Oh, he definitely can.
Oh, he definitely...
Okay.
He can't, though.
Don't do it.
Oh, shoot.
But he's like spawn camping.
It's like watching someone enjoy a...
A black and white film.
Okay, this is good.
No, it's not.
Wait, that guy is climbing.
No!
Oh my gosh, this sucks.
This sucks!
Oh.
Oh, wait, there's no ground here.
Oh my gosh, I can't trap them.
No!
Please!
Okay, I'm gonna have to assert lupinim.
I'm lupinim.
Okay.
Run!
Go!
160 IQ monks.
Lupin the third!
Maybe I can...
Oh, shoot.
I don't know.
Wait, I'm gonna die!
I think...
Uh-oh.
Actually, I think I'm trapped.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
Uh-oh.
I think I messed up.
Wait, I can't blast my way out of here.
Oh, gotta blast!
It wouldn't let me blast if you were stuck in the hole.
Dang.
I have to blast down, but it wouldn't let me.
Hold on.
Let me check the controls again.
It just says blast a hole right, blast a hole left.
And then there's use tool, but I don't have any tools.
Yet.
I think it's the key and stuff that I'll get.
I think you can dig while hanging.
Okay.
You need room to blast.
This one's kind of tricky.
Yeah, because how am I supposed to get that one?
Because it's like...
It's the incline...
This here, right?
Huh?
Yeah, there's no jumping.
Mysterious.
Can you blast while standing above it?
Let's practice.
Oh, wait.
I only have eight lives.
I only have a couple lives.
Oh, my God.
Ah!
Oh, my God!
Okay, I can't blast.
Can't blast.
Oh.
Wait, but I'm trapped now.
Wait.
Uh, no.
Yeah, I can't blast.
And they also can't get me.
Uh, but I'm trapped.
Yeah, I'm trapped.
Uh, 100%.
But how am I supposed to get this?
Maybe I don't even need to get the gold.
Maybe I just get the key and go.
Blast right.
I am...
I am pressing it.
It doesn't let me.
I'm trying to blast to the left.
Nothing.
Maybe...
Oh, shoot.
I just killed myself.
Meow.
Why is it...
So aggressive.
Oh, I think I get it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, okay.
Hold on.
Yeah, you guys leave.
Leave me alone.
Okay, hold on.
So, here.
Oh.
What the?
No!
When I dropped, I dropped down, down.
That's weird.
Okay, hold on.
Blast!
Ah-ha!
Is it gonna eat me?
Oh, but they respawn.
And for me...
For me...
I have to...
I just die.
This is so unfair.
So unfair.
Okay, I think I get it.
We'll get this one first, then.
Since it's a little tricky.
It's a little tricky of a scenario.
Blast!
Oh, blast!
Oh, oh, gosh.
I did not see that.
This is running in DOS box.
It is!
We can press CTRL-F11, CTRL-F12 to reduce or increase the emulated CPU speed.
CTRL-F11?
Or would it be F12?
Blast!
Ah!
It is going up!
It's going up!
Thank you!
I saw it going up.
Look at him go!
This, everything is so smooth now.
Oh, my gosh.
It's so smooth.
Maybe it's...
Okay, so we just gotta have one guy on the...
Thing.
Yeah, thank you so much.
Apparently...
I can't read.
I'm sorry.
I'm getting chased by...
By these guys.
Fantasy Star 4.
4.
Okay, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run to the other side.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run to the other side!
I have a friend that's really into Fantasy Star Online.
But I've never played any of the Fantasy Star games.
PSO.
Now they don't know what to do.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, yes, yes, yes, yes.
This is good.
Because now we just need one guy.
Blast!
And...
And he's confused!
Blast!
And they're confused!
And I'm not confused!
Ah!
Okay, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
We need to somehow get the key!
We need to have them follow me up here, you know?
Follow, follow, follow!
Yeah, come out, come out.
Okay.
No, don't turn around!
Oh.
Don't turn around, please!
Oh my gosh.
How am I supposed to get this dangie?
Oh.
Ah!
Last!
It's not a walk-over-it situation, everybody.
It's not a you-walk-on-top-of-it-and-you-grab-it situation.
Oh, man!
It's a grab-item-button situation.
Yes, indeed, it is.
Yes, indeed.
That is the situation here.
I'm bringing you up the latest news of this game.
In 2025, game is from...
1994?
Probably, I think.
Hot off the press.
This game.
Beep.
Oh, wait.
I need them to follow me.
What am I doing?
No, no, no.
Come here, come here, come here.
Come here, guys.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you want to come down here so bad.
You want to follow me up.
No, you do!
You want to follow me up this ladder.
You're my little groupies, please!
Please, please, come after me.
Please, come after me.
Okay, yeah.
They're playing hard to get, everybody.
Okay.
We're running.
We're...
You need to taunt them?
I need to tease them a little bit, maybe?
Oh, I forgot that one right there.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh my gosh.
I completely forgot about this one.
Oh.
Okay, the game is freaking out a little bit.
That's okay.
Actually, this is the most ideal situation.
Grab!
And I think I need to press this to use.
Use!
Use.
Use, please.
Use the key.
Oh, gosh.
Uh, guys?
Guys?
Uh, why isn't it using the key?
Oh!
I was pressing the wrong button.
That was so close.
Three is to drop bombs.
I don't have those.
For fuck's sake!
Thank you so much for 15 months.
Thank you!
Minto teasing too much.
Wow.
Uh, how, uh...
Uh, maybe...
I don't...
I don't know.
What gets these guys going?
Okay.
I don't know how I'm supposed to get up there.
We'll figure it out.
I believe in us.
Weep!
Sometimes the music is really kind of spooky.
Okay, we're gonna step on this man's head.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, that guy just came down here.
You can't do that.
Try it.
I was only...
I was really relieved that we only had one guy to worry about.
Oh, wait.
Maybe we needed him to steal the jemmies.
You think?
Logan!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
Wait, he just dropped one.
Why'd you do that?
Pew!
He was baiting me?
Wait, he can't get up here.
Oh, I believe we are at an impasse.
How am I supposed to get up there?
The year is 1994.
Friends premieres in the US.
The Lion King hits the movie theaters worldwide.
Becoming a sensation overnight and Lode Runner The Legend Returns is being played by a ghost maid online.
Digital ghost maid.
Yaoi!
Defeat them and see where they respawn.
Oh, so true!
Hello!
Hello, come here!
Come here, my handsome...
cloaked, mysterious man!
Come, come, come, come.
Come, come, come.
Wouldn't...
How hasn't it always been your life's goal to be in a hole of my making?
Okay, now if I stay up here, they might grab it, no?
Alright, grab those two gems with your hands.
Nice!
Greedy, greedy, greedy.
Oh, he didn't grab it.
Oh, he dropped it and then said, nah, I'm going.
Come here, come here.
Oh wait, I need to make the holes.
Drop!
And drop!
Wait, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh my god.
Ah!
Sorry, that scared me.
Okay, we'll have...
We'll stand on top of this guy and see where he spawns.
And see if he...
Oh, there we go.
Someone will grab it.
They're so fast to...
To...
To respawn, you know?
Okay, hold on.
Or to climb out is what I mean.
Ah, he grabbed it!
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Alright, now drop it.
That's a horrible way to die.
I always think about...
Whenever I think about being buried alive...
Have you guys ever played Corpse Party?
The...
PSP remake.
Um, not the original, original.
But, um, the voice acting in that...
There's one ending where one of the characters gets buried alive.
And it's so...
Like...
Man was working for his paycheck.
For real, though.
Like, it's crazy.
He sounds so crazy.
Freaked me out.
Yeah, me too!
I think I'm faster than them, for sure, so...
And they're also a little stupid.
But yeah...
If you want a pretty freaky...
Performance of someone getting buried alive, I suggest that.
Okay, two men in the honey pit.
Wow.
Oh, I moved!
Oh, no!
Oh, wait.
Can I blast from here?
I can!
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Well, that...
Oh!
Oh my god!
What the hell?!
Wait!
Why did I fall so far?
How have I fallen so...
How could I have fallen so far?
How could...
How could this happen to me?
I hate fake floors.
Yeah, I tricked!
I got bamboozled!
I got...
Absolutely demolished there.
How the mighty have fallen.
Oh!
Wait, though!
I didn't even grab onto the bar, did I?
I don't think so.
Because if I grab onto the bar, shouldn't I be able to walk over him?
Unless I can't...
Hold on.
Let's see if he can grab onto the bar.
I don't...
Oh, but he can reach pretty high up.
Could he grab my toes?
I can't tell.
Let's try that again.
Oh, I was using the num...
Not numpad.
Oh!
Grab.
Oh
my gosh!
He's so fast!
He's so slick!
Why is he so...
Bait him!
Okay, I'm gonna show him my ankles.
I gotta go fast.
Okay.
Let's continue onwards.
See what else we got around going on around here, you know?
Bing!
Let's grab the obvious ones that we can grab.
Oh, that guy's waiting for me now.
This game is making me think of Hearts of Darkness on PlayStation for some reason.
Did you ever play that one?
I don't think so.
This song is so unserious.
I wonder what happens if you go into the honey...
Planning
my strategies right now.
You may be wondering...
What strategies?
That's a great question.
That's a really good question.
Do you think he can come get me here?
Okay, I think we'll have to trap him right here.
Come on!
No?
Uh...
I thought we would.
Will he get stuck?
I'm the stuck one!
Oh, and I can't shoot.
I can't blast either while I'm stuck in the honey.
Okay.
We live and learn.
But in this case...
Because one, I am dead.
And also...
I keep dying.
I am dying and learning.
I only have two lives left.
What am I going to get bombs?
Too sticky.
Let's grab...
These first.
This music really is so unserious, isn't it?
This music really is just like...
Wait a second.
Oh!
Okay.
One moment.
Okay, I'm going to have to be so fast.
Oh, wait.
I can't blast it.
I can't blast the wall.
Dang it.
I was going to blast it.
And then send him down.
And then put him in here.
And then...
Walk.
Honey.
An invincible, impenetrable barrier.
Just like real life.
I want some honey now.
Do you guys do that?
Where you eat your local honey?
So you don't have allergies?
Or as bad of allergies?
Quiet, Fox.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
And Vivian.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
I remember being so terrible at this.
Clearly...
I guess I am too.
I guess...
Does that work?
I don't know.
I like to believe it's a placebo if it doesn't work.
If it doesn't work...
If it does work, that's cool.
But if it doesn't work, then...
Maybe I can trick myself into not having allergies anymore.
But supposedly that's a thing.
Where...
If you eat the honey of your local area...
Then you are consuming...
The power of the bees.
And it helps you make...
Be...
Become stronger.
And...
To...
Have better tolerance against...
The...
The pollen.
I'm telling all of this to the guy from behind the other side of the wall.
I'm like...
Hey, did you know?
Did you know that if you...
Eat...
Honey...
Your local area...
It's like that meme of the guy in the club.
He's like talking to the girl and she doesn't care.
Oh...
Cue...
Cue the music.
Cut...
Fade out.
There we go.
Oh gosh, I forgot this happened again.
Okay.
Now I'm...
Now, now I'm stuck.
I think the idea is you're micro dosing on the pollen and the honey...
And the honey to build tolerance.
But we power...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the same thing.
Someone get the butter.
Someone help me...
Oh...
I don't know...
Wait...
Will he drop as well?
I wonder...
Why not just eat the bees?
The honey thing is apparently false.
No!
Don't tell me that!
Who told you, Snopes?
He asked the Jeeves!
Oh!
My Google says it's true.
I'm gonna ask Google AI.
It's always right.
Hold on.
Can...
If...
If I eat...
Honey...
Oh!
Can you...
You can't give honey to babies.
I learned that recently.
Good thing I don't have a baby.
Honey.
But I said...
I searched if I eat honey.
And some of the things were...
If I eat honey while pregnant...
Can I eat honey while breastfeeding?
Why?
It's...
Botulism.
Yeah...
Yeah, don't give honey to babies.
Good thing I'm also not a babysitter.
Wait, if I eat...
Local...
Honey...
Allergies.
I'm just gonna...
Eat...
Local honey allergies.
That's...
That's what I'll write.
I'll send.
Okay, send.
Send tweet.
The claim that eating local honey can alleviate allergies is a popular but unproven folk remedy.
There is no scientific evidence to support the effectiveness of local honey for allergies.
No!
I've been spreading lies.
I've been spreading lies on the internet.
Uh-oh.
Honey can cause botulism sores.
Which can be dangerous for infants under one year of age.
People with bee allergies may experience allergic reactions to honey.
That was...
Those are the potential risks.
You...
Cancel me, phantom for misinformation.
Botulism is a nerve toxin.
It's also botox.
What?
No.
Are you pulling my like...
Buies are the friends.
Yeah, they are.
I'm gonna say...
Placebo.
No, that's true.
He's not lying.
What?
It is botox.
What is botox?
What...
Is botox?
Wait, so people would get botulism and then afterwards they'd be like, oh my gosh.
And my skin is also...
My skin is also as soft as a baby's bottom.
Thank you for the thank you to thank you.
Today Mint learns middle school science.
I don't know what you guys are learning in middle school.
Botul...
Bot...
Botulinum toxin.
Whoa.
A potent neurotoxin protein produced by anaerobic bacterium clod...
Clostridium botulinum...
Bot...
Botulinum...
KCI...
Wait.
What is it?
Lacti...
KCI...
Shiroda.
Wait, la...
No.
Hold on.
Lactobacillus KCI...
Shiroda.
That is...
Yakult.
Lact...
Lactobacillus KCI...
Shiroda.
Okay.
Should I get out of this problem?
The BGM goes so well with this.
I love Yakult.
It's so good.
Okay, what I'm gonna try is I'm going to get on top and I'm gonna hang.
And then I'm gonna bait him over to me.
And then I'm gonna fall.
And then I'm gonna run under him.
That's the plan.
Okay,
he had the same plan.
Okay.
New plan.
I hear eating local ghost girls will make you...
Wait.
Make me freakier.
This is true.
Could I sell my ectoplasm like honey?
Now say prestigious.
What about it?
I'll make my own music.
The music stopped at like the perfect time.
Okay, guys.
I'm accepting new ideas for my business venture of how to get the hell out of here.
Who wants to be in the shark tank?
Even the game was shocked.
Does the screen wrap?
No.
Botox is used to eliminate wrinkles by tightening up muscles through localized paralysis?
That's what it is!
That's freaky.
Try baiting him out of there from the left.
Baiting who?
Which one?
There's two guys.
I heard it's used as a treatment for migraines.
Yeah, actually I was told that I should get the Botox for my migraines.
But...
I'm...
I don't do any of that.
That stuff scares me.
Ver-ver-verish multitude.
It's my favorite word.
Did I say it right?
Pre-ordering my case of gamer ghost girl ectoplasm?
Yeah, brain Botox.
Nice and smooth.
You guys mean bait?
I don't think I can...
I might be able to bait this guy.
The guy on the right is what you mean?
The people I know that tried it said it worked.
Really?
Wow.
Yeah, I don't know though.
I actually haven't gotten many migraines recently, so...
Yahoo!
Glad YouTube recommended me one of your covers.
It got me hooked.
What?
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
I have a new cover coming out soon!
Looking forward to having smooth brain.
But...
I got the final mix for the song today.
There was one part...
Oh my gosh.
Bless the mixer.
I kept...
Recording this one part.
I was like, I'm sorry!
I just don't like...
I was being...
I was being like so hyper critical.
But I think now it sounds really good.
The whole thing sounds really good.
One jar of cute ghost made ectoplasm please.
I have to figure out how to harness it.
Okay.
I did go this way before.
Let's just try it.
Beep.
Okay, you...
See, he just kind of chills here.
That's what I thought would happen.
Oh.
No, never mind.
I was gonna say, I forgot to get the gold from the other side.
But I can still get it.
Yeah, yeah.
I can still get it.
Hi, Minky.
Hi.
I need to get this mister up here.
You, mister, mister, mister.
Come here.
I don't know how to bait him out.
Hit him with the...
Hit
him with the...
I think I have to be really fast.
Maybe I drop and then...
Blast another hole.
And have him drop.
I think.
I think I drop down here.
Like, I drop down.
Exactly where I blast this hole.
And then blast the hole to the right of...
Or to... Yeah, to my right.
I think.
Come, my game is absurd!
Thank you!
Trapped one of my small Minky plushies in the cup.
The other plushie is still at large in my walls.
Uh oh.
Probably...
Like a whole infestation now.
Sounds right?
That makes sense?
Okay, let's do it.
Let's do it!
I was...
Why did I wait?
Aw, they buried me!
Game over.
Oh no, that's it?
Wait, is that really it?
I like how he kinda looks like the Grim Reaper.
Do I have to start over?
What's this?
Oh, there's also a build your own level, you guys.
Look at this.
Look, look, look.
We can make anything we want.
I can make it day, I can make it night, I can make it...
Oh!
Spoilers?
Whoa!
One game I really want to play this week...
Sorry, by the way, that I haven't put out my schedule.
I've been trying to like...
Figure it out.
But, um...
Because one thing I want to play this week is the Jurassic Park Arcade.
But I'm trying to figure out how I can make it work.
Since I...
Without a light gun...
Mori Calliope sends her regards.
Yeah, we're in hell.
You know?
Oh!
I covered it...
In sand.
No!
Wait, this is a literal curse.
What?
Undo!
Why doesn't it explain what anything...
What any of these buttons do?
Wait, I can write text.
Thank you!
Where'd it go?
Oh!
Aw, yeah!
Is this undo?
What's this?
You must...
Have saved a level group before you can add new levels.
Oh.
No.
Um, okay.
So this is, I guess, like, if I want to send it to somebody.
What's this do?
Oh!
Wait, where's Minky?
Wait, we can carve out Minky.
Play the dirt level.
Play it!
Wait.
Is this not undo?
I feel like it should be, right?
No?
Okay, okay, hold on.
Move this over a little bit.
Minky.
And a heart.
I played that arcade game all the time as a little wisp.
I feel like this pulp.
Getting it working goes well.
Yeah!
Like, I wanna...
I'm trying to figure out a way.
How I can make it.
But it's also...
I just wanna play it at the same time.
Now, how do I make the ladders?
What's this do?
What?
Maybe that's the undo button.
What's this do?
Oh, I can...
I can...
Oh!
We can be this guy.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
And he goes.
Okay!
Okay, okay.
Yeah, you can select every...
Oh, oops.
Redo.
Okay.
And then...
Oh, I have to hold down.
Skull.
So many skulls.
Oh, I keep pressing the wrong button.
It's so...
It's like a little swirly.
So, it's kinda getting me excited.
Um...
And then, what does this do?
A paint...
Let's just try everything.
Let's try everything.
Wait, what is this?
What a thrill.
Oh, no.
Redo.
Oh, wow.
Wow, this gets really...
Complicated, no?
What's that do?
I don't know.
We're gonna figure it out.
This...
Oh, these are the tiles.
This is...
What does this do?
I'm figuring it out.
This is our test run.
What's this do?
I'll figure it out.
And then a man.
Up here.
Bring the baddies.
The minky is full of baddies.
Wait, can I only have so many baddies?
No!
The game says you cannot be cruel.
Each letter has a body.
Minky's the body.
My gamersup's income has arrived.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna be completely honest with you guys.
Um...
I...
I completely forget to check, like...
My...
Um...
Uh...
The money that I get from the gamersup stuff.
Like, all the time.
Like, I...
They are...
They will...
They'll, like, message me and be like, Hey!
Like, um...
Do you...
Are you...
Do you want this?
And...
Like, do you want us to send this to you?
And, um...
And...
But...
You know...
With all the other stupid nonsense that had gone around...
Um...
Actually...
Uh...
I completely forgot about the...
The cups and everything.
And...
Um...
Then...
I got paid from that!
And it...
Oh my gosh...
You don't...
I was like...
Cause I was gonna use the other money from my merch for, like...
My 3D and things like that.
But...
But that...
That...
You guys ordering stuff from the gamersup...
Like...
It saved me...
So much...
So thank you guys!
Thank you guys so much!
I really...
I was like...
Oh man...
This is like...
Actually...
A pretty big hit!
I don't like talking about...
Buddy with you guys...
Cause I don't want you guys to like...
Feel any pressure to...
Do anything or anything like that...
But...
I just wanted to...
I wanted to let you guys know that...
You really did me a solid there!
So thank you!
Okay, let's go try these out!
Oh...
Oh yeah!
What's this do?
Oh, I have to pick it up...
Okay, we have a thing...
What's this do?
Uh...
Nothing...
Doesn't do anything...
Okay...
Ow!
That's what it does!
It appears!
It appears on one side...
Okay...
Use item!
Will this kill me?
Nope...
Oh no, wait!
I put the other things on top!
I can't get them!
Uh-oh!
Beep beep boop!
My...
Oh, she is dying!
No!
It's a stink gun!
Wait, what did this do?
Oh, I dropped it!
Um...
I might have to redo my level...
One moment, please!
I have to reconsider my level!
I feel pressured to donate $20 now!
Not because of what you said, but because you were going with the sauce!
Keep it up, Minto!
The sauce!
What kind of sauce?
I hope I'm...
Sweet and sour!
That's what I always get with my chicken nuggies!
Oh yeah, give me that good ol' sweet and sour sauce!
Sweet, sour, sweet and sour!
Ecto sauce!
What was the one...
What was the...
What was the Rick and Morty sauce?
Oh, she's dead!
Let's gooo!
Beep!
What's this do now?
Pick up...
And use...
Use...
Oh, I cover the ground in honey!
Oh, it's a one-time use!
I still don't know what this thing is, but...
Okay...
Okay, what's this?
I'm assuming this makes me dig down...
No!
What does this do?
I don't know...
I'm really glad that buying some of your stuff helped you out with the money at least...
Thank you!
Yeah!
I tried jumping...
It didn't work...
20 pieces...
Minto nugget with ectoplasm sauce...
Large ghost...
No bath water!
No, no, no!
PSU's come over!
Yeah!
I dropped $10!
No!
Thank you for the...
Thank you!
Okay, watch this!
Oh!
They're obsessed with me, for real!
Okay, hold on...
Can I blast?
No...
Wait, hold on...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna blast it...
No, I'm not...
I'm gonna blast...
Blast...
There...
Uh...
Wait...
Okay...
And...
Release the stink!
Oh, I did it up...
Oh!
Wait, we're just disconnected...
Ah!
What's happening?
We're okay...
Wait...
Oh!
I know, I just disconnected...
I just murdered them!
Everything's fine!
Everything's okay!
The stink cloud...
Worked!
It saved me!
Sim!
Welcome to Muppet Ship!
Thank you!
The stink cloud...
Saved me from actual death...
In this...
What a thrill...
Okay...
Let's get back to the actual game...
Oh, sorry...
I was pressing my...
OBS...
That's what I've been looking at...
The OBS projector...
Okay...
Main menu...
Yeah...
No...
What's this one?
Multiplayer?
Oh, what's this one?
Oh...
Okay, if I wanna load one...
What's this?
Wait...
You!
Oh my god...
Wait...
Who grabbed which key?
Use, use, use...
Use...
Oh shoot...
You have that key...
Use...
Oh wait...
Oh gosh...
Okay...
Use...
Use key...
Oh...
I don't know how to use...
Oh my gosh...
I need to get Doki in...
And play this together...
My friend is dead...
Wait...
What's this do?
Oh...
Oops...
Too bad it's...
Too bad it's local...
I missed out on the cup to take...
To take...
This to pretend I got this...
No!
Wait, no!
It's way too much!
I may help you do it well...
DAKU!
Look at these guys...
They don't know what to do without me...
Do I have to start at...
Level one?
That seems to be the case...
But now we're faster...
And smarter...
More brilliant...
You could say...
You could say that I...
Can you do save states?
I don't know...
I've never actually used DOS box before...
Pirate, help!
You told me earlier...
How to increase the frame rate!
Haddle for me!
Too!
See you, thank you, welcome back!
Speaking of sauces and nuggies...
What's your favorite...
Snack...
Besides the stale popcorn?
My favorite snack?
Okay...
I haven't been in the stale popcorn...
But...
There's these...
They're like snap peas...
But I don't like peas...
But they're...
I don't remember what they're called...
But they're really yummy!
Jelly?
Okay, wait...
That actually might be my favorite snack...
It's the world famous blackjack player...
Mint Phantom...
That's me!
Double down, double down, double down...
All in, all in, all in...
Double down!
Have you ever played Elder Scrolls?
I've never played a single Elder Scrolls before...
So no...
Wait...
Oblivion is Elder Scrolls, no?
There's no save states in Vanilla DOS box...
Shoot...
Well thank you...
Thanks for letting me know...
Then I have played Elder Scrolls Oblivion...
That's it...
Oblivion doesn't count?
Wait...
No, it should!
That's what I'm saying...
Should count!
Beep beep beep...
Monkey, monkey, monkey...
Monkey, monkey, monkey, monkey...
Should play the other sometime?
I've been really itching for like a...
What do you call...
Just like a...
I don't...
I don't know...
I'm just gonna...
Okay...
I've been itching for like a David Cage game...
I don't want to...
Play a David Cage game...
But just a game like...
Of that kind of...
You know...
Okay...
Alright, our first...
Our first red guy...
What's...
What level did I get to?
Do you guys remember?
Do you guys remember what level we got to before?
Wait, how do I get up there again?
Up, up, up, up...
Up to the top!
Eating ragtars!
Yes!
Thank you!
Deadly premonition!
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
That's perfect!
I've been wanting to play that...
Wait, hold on...
Let me write that down...
So I don't forget...
Blade Runner and now Load Runner...
I'm just running...
Is this the games I played on my dad's PC Nostalgia stream arc?
Kinda?
It's not...
Not that...
Yeah, false, stupid...
I haven't bought it yet...
Oh, wait...
Oh, shoot...
Oh...
Oh, here we go...
I'm an idiot...
There we go...
Ghost Runner...
Someone make a mod of this game...
Where it's me running from...
What would I...
I don't run from anything...
No, it would be...
You guys running from...
Me...
This guy from a trip?
Oh, yeah...
Happy birthday!
Okay...
Oh...
Yeah, yeah, yeah...
Keep running...
What happens if you catch us?
Um...
Do you not...
See...
That guy left a skull on the ground!
Oh, I didn't even know he took that!
What a...
Little...
Sneak...
Ground!
Now I'm gonna have to go grab it!
Oh...
My...
God...
Haha!
I had to run there anyway...
That's true!
I can't believe that guy...
Stole my...
Gold!
This one was kinda silly...
I don't remember...
I wish I could do save states...
I'm not gonna lie...
Really wish I could do save states...
Meow!
I like the way they just kinda like...
Hold themselves up down there like...
Wow!
I guess I'll give up!
That's what he says...
Okay...
I'm actually getting so good at this game...
If you wanna do Deadly Premonition...
Try...
Mystery of the Druids...
Oh, I think some...
You guys told me about that, no?
Pretty sure...
Yeah, yeah...
If you wanna do more...
Old DOS games in the future...
You should look in the DOS Box X...
It's also free...
It has more...
Game-oriented features...
Like save states...
Not sponsored...
Oh!
Thank you!
I will try it next time...
Save states would be so nice here, no?
I have 10 lives though...
Could be where...
The music is just...
Sometimes...
Really...
Really something...
Oh!
Oh, shoot!
I messed that up...
Oh no!
Wait...
I might need to make another hole...
Okay...
You walk...
Yeah...
And then I run...
Perfect...
Oh my gosh...
Couldn't have gone better...
Honestly...
It's kind of really... It's kind of really cursed how it just kind of...
Oh my god.
Okay, we need to get to the top.
Bop bop bop bop to the top.
MGS... V... Wait, where did that guy come from?
Co-op?
Wait, what?
MGSP playthrough with friends or wisps?
Wait, that'd be awesome.
I did not see it though, Micmac.
Okay, we drop.
We dropping.
Where are we dropping, boys?
Down here.
And fall and fall and I do be running.
And the music do be stopping.
Oh my god.
That?
What the hell was that?
Oh, what the hell was that?
Now I'm trapped.
Wait, oh my gosh.
No, no, no.
Okay.
That was so unfair.
What was that spawn point?
What the hell?
What the hell was that?
This chair is not... I got a new chair.
I don't know if I told you guys I got a new chair.
And it's kinda nice.
But...
But the...
It hurts if I'm wearing like...
Shorts.
It's not nice on my legs.
The material, you know?
So I usually have like a blanket.
New chair fun.
No, I love my chair.
It's one of those like crisscross applesauce chairs.
So I can just...
I sit in very unusual ways.
And it allows me to do so.
Quite easily.
Oh, I think I...
Sprayed that...
Too early.
Maybe.
No.
Oh.
They make those?
Yeah.
Yeah, they do.
I like...
I'm constantly...
Sitting like...
Crazy ways.
So...
It's actually super helpful.
Okay.
Perfect.
It wasn't too early at all.
Uh oh.
Oh shoot.
Ow.
Yeah, there we go.
Oh!
Ah!
Ha ha ha!
Heee...
Ha ha ha ha!
Everything's fun!
We're chill!
We're chill, right guys?
We're chill.
Original Blair Witch Game Trilogy.
Not the...
From the 2000s.
Not the 2019 one.
I don't think the dog dies on the 2019 one.
I think you saved the dog.
It's just...
The dog gets gravely injured.
And so it's still...
Bad.
Do you guys ever sometimes watch videos of...
Whoops.
Why isn't it?
Why am I not going?
There we go.
Videos of...
People spoiling...
Movies.
Okay.
So it's like...
They're spoiling...
For this...
In this context...
They spoil...
Horror movies.
And...
It's mainly because like...
Sometimes you never know...
Horror movies are like...
Such a hit or miss.
Sometimes with like...
What's in it.
I don't know.
For example...
Like...
If they're like...
Oh, we're just gonna kill the dog.
Dogs are an AI.
No, they're not.
But...
I watched one...
And sometimes I'll do it...
If I'm like...
Not sure if I'll like a movie or not.
I did one...
There's that new movie that came out...
Like...
I think it's called...
Together.
And it's like a...
Really...
It's like a...
Apparently it's like a super body horror.
What the hell?
Leave me alone.
So I was like...
I don't really do body horror well...
But I'm still...
Cur...
Curious...
About it.
Gaming.
We're gaming.
Holy...
And so...
I watched one of those today.
Where...
Where was I going with this?
I don't...
I don't quite remember.
I think...
Oh!
Uh...
It was about the movie because...
Um...
Because...
I love horror, but... Oops.
I messed it up again.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
There we go.
The game is on my side.
Better at the beginning than at the end.
Right!
Yeah.
So, I guess warning for anybody who was gonna go see that... Go see that movie.
I love the Metal Gear stage.
This one's great.
Okay, they haven't stolen any of the things yet.
Which is pretty nice.
Don't do that.
Okay, good.
Wait, he stole it!
What?
A little bastard.
Taking that... Getting that five-finger discount.
John Wick teaches you why you don't kill dogs.
John Wick was... It's like the only movie that I will probably watch that has that kind of content.
I'm not gonna lie.
I don't mess around with... With pets, you know?
And stuff.
I really don't.
Red Bros are confused.
WHOA!
No way.
What?
That guy had the worst spawn ever!
Oh my gosh.
I was just gonna keep running.
Good thing I looked.
No, this one was hell.
No.
This one was hell.
I don't wanna do it again.
Who put these ladders everywhere?
These guys are sick and twisted.
This is actually Death Stranding.
That's also in Death Stranding.
Who put these ladders everywhere?
John Wick is awesome.
Yeah, but you guys, I'm like an empath.
So like, when an animal dies, I get sad.
I'm an empath.
We've only lost one life.
That's pretty good.
I'm proud of us, team.
I'm proud of us, chat.
My empath Oshi.
I'm an empath.
Me,
boys.
Follow me.
No, no.
Follow me, boys.
You know you want... Oh, shoot.
Oh, I messed up.
Change of plans, boys.
Wait.
Yeah, they'll keep going up.
Oh.
Follow me, boys.
Follow me.
Follow-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f-f
Oh, they're so stupid.
Oh, you guys are so simple.
Simple little...
Collect
everything before I use... I guess so.
I guess it unlocks it and then the portal...
Oh, this one again.
Okay.
This is going to hurt me a lot more than it hurts you.
Wahoo!
Okay.
Guys, I'll be honest, I don't really know...
I don't really have a plan for how long today's stream is.
Um...
He just took that!
I just saw him!
I just saw him take that!
And you take that one.
Good, good.
Good job, good job, good job.
Beep boop!
Oh, and he just left it.
Okay.
That works too.
That works.
I run and grab this...
And then you reincarnate...
And I grab these...
Beep beep!
Don't go up that ladder!
That's not for you!
Oh, he didn't grab it.
Okay, he kind of sucks.
I wonder if he'll follow me.
That's awkward.
Oh, wait.
No, no, no.
You're not supposed to follow me.
Wait, no!
You're not supposed to follow me!
No, please!
Okay.
Oh, he took it!
He took it!
Yeah, I know you couldn't resist, you criminal scum.
Um...
And then I go up.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, wait, though.
Actually, this is good.
I think.
Why wouldn't they follow you?
I don't know.
They're just so obsessed with me or something.
They're obsessed with me or something.
Just like us?
Really?
We made it back!
Okay, so it's level 10 is our trouble spot.
Oh, golly.
I don't know.
He's not a criminal.
You're the one robbing the place.
In style.
Huzzah!
I'm not obsessed.
No?
Not yet.
Okay, let's grab the easy ones first.
Ew.
Now that I know that I can get a stink gun and I can get a bucket that throws honey on the people, I feel really... like I'm just missing out.
I wonder where the portal will appear to...
It kind of will make me determine which way...
Like, do I go for this one first?
Or do I go for the ones on the left first, you know?
I left for a while and how are you still at this level?
I just got back here!
What are you talking about?
We just got here!
Defeat the one on the left to earn time...
on the honey.
Not sure where respawn is.
But I also can't bait him out.
That's the issue.
I don't know how to get him out.
When he's in there?
When he like gets inside there?
When I drop down?
He...
He acts like a total weirdo.
I wish when I grabbed this one I didn't fall all the way completely to the bottom.
It makes no sense.
Oh wait!
Oh, that's right!
I was gonna blast him.
I remember.
I was gonna drop and...
and do that thing.
I remember.
I messed it up because I was too slow.
Okay.
I was too slow.
Wah!
Oh, there he is.
Actually, wait.
I'm gonna kill you?
Oh.
Nevermind.
Okay, redo redo.
Let me...
Let me let him spawn.
Okay, hold on.
Oh sh...
I was slow again.
Why do I keep doing that?
I think I'm like just being overly cautious of how fast the holes...
You know?
Okay.
Die!
Okay, nice.
Oh, that's...
Ooh...
Me when it's a full mood.
Ow!
Let's go.
How do I get back to the other side?
Hmm...
How do I get back over there?
Oh, I see.
Yes.
Oh, I found it out.
Alright.
We're gonna get this.
And then...
Oh, you're kidding me.
This
guy!
This guy!
If I fall, he falls!
I don't know how to joke him.
Okay, hold on.
I did it!
I'm a gamer.
I might be a gamer.
Oh, he made it!
We made it!
Starting into Donnie.
Why do I always get called Donnie?
Oh, no.
What?
They're all over the place.
This one's kind of freaky.
Wait, this one's freaky freaky.
What's the best course of action here?
Okay.
Probably?
Well...
What a gamer.
Nice juking gamer.
Thank you.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Oh, uh...
That's not what I meant to do.
Run, run, run.
Oh no!
Okay, they're stupid.
They're for real stupid.
Beep!
I have a feeling...
I have a feeling the portal's going to be up there.
That's my hunch.
That's gonna be up there in the right corner.
Because why else would this ladder exist?
It goes to nowhere!
Minky, minky, minky.
My dad played this while we watched for hours cheering every level he got more than last run.
Yeah!
Same!
Hey!
Who is hunch?
No.
It's my hunchback.
My gamer posture.
Because now I'm an actual gamer.
I'm a gamer, I'm a gamer.
I'm a gamer and a dreamer.
I'm a gamer and a dream...
Oh no, no.
I'm a gamer, I'm a gamer, I'm a gamer and a dreamer.
Just keep going in circles.
Never let them know your next move.
Except that you're going in circles.
That's okay.
How'd they know that?
Drop.
Beep beep.
Ow.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
I messed up.
Bottom of the screen!
Because there's no grass.
Grass.
There's no grass down there.
Oh, I have to go here.
Okay.
And then blast it.
Perfect.
What the?
Oh, what?
That's crazy.
First try.
Oh,
I think I see how to get out.
Oh, okay.
I see.
Oh, I have to go up.
Up, up, up.
Wait, but how do I get to this?
Oh.
Ah, this one sucks.
Oh, my God.
Did you just drop down?
You s- Oh, you sons of bitches.
You're ruining my whole plan.
Dan.
This sucks.
Not even the music likes this level.
Stop.
Beep beep.
Can I?
I guess they could technically drop down, can't they?
Oh, yes.
They can.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
And they're stealing my gold.
Stop it.
Oh my god, they dropped another piece.
Go, go, go!
Sorry.
Oh no.
Dang it.
I pressed, I pressed the wrong key.
Out of desperation.
The red guys are canonically robots based on the game's lore.
No, wait, there's lore in this.
Oh, this level is not as easy as I think it would be.
This level is a little more tricky than meets the eye.
And you see this guy right here?
I think that's where the door will appear.
Because then you have to go all the way up here to get into it.
That is my sneaking... Oh, actually, no.
Probably not.
Oh wait.
No, you have to go up here to go to this one anyway.
Never mind.
Just kidding.
Bomberman's an NES version.
Really?
Wait.
Oh.
You know what?
I'm just gonna keep running.
You guys didn't take any of my money, did you?
Actually, it will probably be...
On that, in the far right.
I probably will have to run all the way over there.
It really hates these stairs.
The music really hates it.
Oh my gosh, they keep dropping my loot!
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, blast.
And blast.
Oh, sh...
Ow!
Is it possible to get the cursor icon here?
It's...
Thank you!
Oh gosh, it was like...
Way back when I...
It was like a...
It was like a long, long time ago.
It was...
Um...
When I like...
Came back...
When I...
Redebute...
So I'm sorry.
I don't remember...
Who the cursor...
Who the artist was.
Or the cursor.
This games look like it'd be really fun to watch a speedrunner beat it.
Right!
I agree.
Okay.
This part...
What are you...
Where are you going?
Excuse you!
He is finding his own way.
I cannot get over how the music sounds in this part.
It's so funny.
Beep!
I don't know why it hates it so much.
It's so funny though.
Okay, they can't get me.
They can't get me there.
And they're too stupid to go any higher.
The guy over there is having his own dance party.
On the far left.
So we're fine.
I thought it was my connection.
Nope!
Random tinnitus.
Beep!
Okay, how do I want to go on my own dance?
Yes.
Oh, he keeps picking it up and dropping it.
What a little...
Oh wait though.
Oh my gosh.
I just realized.
How am I supposed to...
Get back up there?
Wait.
No, no, no.
He killed me!
Wait.
I have to do this one first.
Oh my gosh.
Over here.
On the left.
Get out, plane.
On the right side.
No!
Oh, I could fall on...
I could go up and then fall onto it.
Okay, that's true.
That's true.
Okay, okay, okay.
Cause I was gonna say, like how the hell am I supposed to...
We're getting new sound effects each time.
It's becoming pee pee music for real.
Now, how are they gonna get me?
Nice.
Oh.
Uh oh.
Not nice.
Oh!
Ow!
Blow on the cartridge.
Wait.
Give me one second, you guys.
Okay.
Wait.
One moment.
One second.
Time zones are so confusing.
Oh.
Wait.
Well, this was fun.
I did enjoy it a lot.
I'm glad that we could play.
Sorry, I'm...
I have a...
A little something something going on.
So...
Time...
I thought...
I got the times all wrong.
I put it wrong in my...
Thanks for the stream, everybody!
I thought it was in an hour from now.
That's okay.
Um...
Uh...
Yeah.
Thank you, everybody!
Control S.
What's that?
Oh, I'm scared.
What is it gonna do?
I'm scared!
Thank you for the fun stream.
Have a good something something.
Thank you!
This...
I'm so sorry to end so abruptly.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
This is fun.
Thank you for letting me be a little boomer sometimes.
Okay.
Control S is saved.
I don't...
I can't read it.
I already exited out.
Okay.
I hope...
I hope this works.
Wait.
Where'd my cursor go?
Okay.
Okay!
Thank you, everybody!
Bye-bye!
Thank you!
Have a good day!
Have a good night!
I'll see you later!
Bye!
I'm so sorry!
Again for ending so abruptly.
Bye!